the craziest thing I've ever seen
without a doubt though is a soccer game
in Argentina my wife's from Argentina we
went to spend Christmas there about 11
12 years ago and I say to my uncle well
to her uncle you know hey can we go can
we go to this game and he gets this very
serious look on his face and he's like
[Music]
we can go we can go he says in Spanish
we can go he goes no women no children I
saw why when we went because we had to
get through I think three police
barricades there was temporary fencing
with barbed wire put up I mean it was
just absolute Madness and police with
riot gear outside and if this is the is
the the field
people were sitting here and people were
sitting here kind of like as if in the
two end zones what would be end zones of
our football and there was nobody
sitting in the best seats right because
that was the distance that people could
throw things and hit each other